안녕하세요 시도입니다 올겨울이 꽤
길었는데 이번 주부터 꽃샘 추위가
시작됐더라 저는 이전 영상에서 소개한
대로 겨울에 히트텍 같은 내복을 안
입는 대신에 두툼한 울 팬츠를 많이
입습니다 그래서 날이 좀 풀리면이
잠자고 있던 청바지를 꺼내 입어요
제가 대님을 정말 좋아하는데 오늘은
제가 자주 입는 대님 친구들을 좀
소개해드리려 합니다 지난 영상보다 좀
더 다양한 가격 제품들로
가져와봤어요 처음 소개해드릴 제품은
리바이스의 오렌지탭 517 라인입니다
최근에 캔드릭 라마가 슈퍼볼에서
선보인 무대와 더불어서이 옷들도
화제였는데요 캔드릭 라마가 입은 옷
중 단연 화제가 된 건 바로
바지였다 때문에 셀리를 비롯한 여러
브랜드의 부츠컷 바지들 판매가
올랐습니다 실제로 부츠컷 대닝 광고도
제 인스타나 유튜브에 자주 뜨더라고요
저도 부츠컷 데님이 몇 개 있는데
그중 가장 잘 입는 건이 리바이스의
57 라인입니다 당연하게도 캔드릭
라마의 셀리네 바지와 사이가 조금
있습니다 셀린느의 부츠 컷은 좀 더
와이드한 피라면이 리바이스의 Oh
라인은 허벅지부터 좀 더 슬림하게
떨어져요 그리고 종아리 쯤부터 통이
커지는 정도가 좀 덜
부담스럽습니다 오렌지 탭이 일반 레드
탭과 얼마나 다른진 솔직히 잘
모르겠습니다 다만 사이즈 참고차
말씀드리면 바지통이 좀 좁게 나와서
저는 평소에 30을 입는데이 제품은
32 사이즈를 갔습니다 그래도 와이드
하진 않지만 허벅지에서 깔끔한
일자핏이 나와서 예쁘더라고요 이렇게
와이드하지 않은 바지는 상체를 부하게
가져가면 그 메이플 스토리 캐릭터처럼
머리랑 상반신만 둥둥 떠다니고 그래서
저는이 대님을 주로 봄여름에 핏의
반팔과 함께 붙여서 입습니다 아우터를
같이 입고 싶다면 제가 입은 크롭한
자켓을 입거나 살랑살랑한 셔츠에
단추를 풀고 입어도 좋을 것 같아요
바지가 지나치게 꾸민 느낌도 캐주얼한
느낌도 나지 않는 제품이라 로퍼나
제가 쉬는 스니커즈 등 어디든 잘
어울립니다 오 레드 탭은 제가
찾아보니까 10만원 내외로 살 수
있으니까요 한번 다가오는 봄에 시도해
보셔도 좋을 것 같습니다 처음을
대중적인 바지로 시작했으니까 두
번째는 디자이너 브랜드의 데님 하나
소개해 드릴게요 이건 한 2년 전쯤
젠테 스토어에서 구매한 보테가
베네타의 데님 팬츠입니다이 데님은
제가 보테가 베네타의 레디투 웨어에
한창 꽂혀 있을 때 좋은 가격에
나와서 고민하다가 구매하게 된
제품이에요 다니엘리 떠난 뒤 마티
블라지 크리에이티브 디렉터 자리를
받고 나서 얼마 안 돼 나왔던
제품으로 기억합니다 다리가 보가
베네타의 새로운 숨결을 불어넣어 뉴
보테가 시작한 장본인이 하지만 마티
블라지 보테가 베네타의 레디투 웨어에
캐주얼하면서도 고급스러운 느낌을 잘
조화시켰다
생각합니다이 대님 팬츠도 그러한데요
전면은 적절한 캐더 들어간 중청
색상입니다 그리고 체결은 버튼 플라이
방식인데 그 본인만 알 수 있는
보테가 그린 컬러 디테일이 있습니다이
디테일은 같이 나온 데님셔츠 동일한
방식으로 들어가 있어요 후면에는
보테가의 상징하는 브 모양 자수가
들어간 두 개의 포켓이 있고 역시나
보테가 그린색의 가죽 비 허리춤에
자리합니다
사실이 두 개가 거의 포인트의
대부분입니다 솔직하게 이거 말고 딱
봤을 때 대단할 건 없는 님이에요
하지만이 후면 디테일이 매력적이고
봄여름에 맞는 초록색이라서 살짝살짝
보이면 예쁩니다 물론 개인적으로이
워싱도 참 잘 나온 바지라고
생각하고요 미디의 길이는 보통이고
밑으로 갈수록 미세하게 좁아지 하지만
거의 일자에 가까운 실루엣입니다 통은
리바이스 517 라인보다 넓은 세미
와이드에 가까운 시예요 호불호 없이
누구나 입을만한 인지라 역시나
스니커즈나 로퍼 전부 다
잘어울립니다 그다음은 르메르의
트위스티드 데입니다 이전에 올린
르메르 영상에서 는데 언젠가 님들과
함께 소개해드리고 싶었던 바지예요이
청바지는 정말 제가 중등학교 시절
교복 이후에 가장 자주 입은 바지라고
자신있게 말할 수 있습니다 제가이
바지를 입은 사진만 해도이 소개 영상
내내 넣을 수 있을 정도더라고요
트위스티드 데님은 어느 무드에 잘
어울리고 평범하진 않지만 그렇다고
너무 튀는 바지도 아닙니다 리추 옆에
달린 심이 내려가면서 갈등 앞쪽으로
떨어져서 우한 실루엣을 만들어 줍니다
허벅지부터 전체적으로 통이 여유롭기
때문에 체형 보완도 되고요 그리고
탈부착 가능한이 데닌 벨트도 넣어
입었을 때 포인트가 되어 줍니다
사시사철 활용도가 좋은 바이기 때문에
르메르를 처음 구매하는 주변
사람들에게 항상 추천하는
품목입니다이 제품 또한 신발은 어떤
걸 신어도 좋고요 전체적으로 르메르
특유에 풍성하면서도 우 느낌을 내고
싶을 때 특효가 되는 아이템입니다
저는 이바지를 입을 때 주로 인어는
넣어 입어서 벨트 디테일을 살려줍니다
여름에는 그냥 흰색 반팔과 같이
입어주고 보면은 셔츠를 넣어 입거나
오버하지 않은 흰색 티셔츠 위해
간단하게 아우터를 입어 주기도 합니다
화려한 상이를 입지 않더라도이 바지의
벨트와 풍성한 실루엣이 포인트가 되기
때문에 잔잔하면서도 매력 있는 모습이
아템으로 크로아상 백도 좋지만 저는
내 시즌 나오는이 트위스트 대임을
강력하게
추천드립니다네 번째 대은 타이가
타카시의 704 데미지드 인디고 이건
지난번 타이가 타카시 영상에서 한차례
소개해드린 적이 있어서 제외하려고
했는데 제가 가장 자주입는 대님 중
하나인 이걸 빼고 영상을 완성할 수가
없더라고요이 대은 정말 주관적인
기준에서 지금까지 제가 본 대님 중에
가장 워싱을 가지고 있습니다이 바지를
보기 전까진 솔직하게 어떤 데이든
중이면 색감이 다 거기서 거기라고
생각했어요 그런 제 생각을 완벽하게
깨준
제품입니다 기존에 타이가 타카이에서
출시한 74 모델의 빈티지 워싱을
진행한 모델인데요 캣워싱 아래로
허벅지를 깊게 타고 내려간 워싱이
봄에 잘 어울리는 연한 색입니다
고증을 살린 서스펜더 단추를 포함한
모든 단추가 살짝
어서이 워싱과 어우러져서 빈티지한
분위기를 한층 더 잘
살려줍니다이 바지는 전체적으로 일자로
떨어지면서 와이드한 실루엣을 지니고
있어요 거기다 빈티지한 색감인 지라
제가 가진 갈색 로퍼 등과 잘
어울리더라고요
이바지는 지난해 구매한 이후 너무
자주 입어서 무릎이 좀 늘어났습니다
도저히 못 입을 지경이 되면 똑같은
제품을 하나 더 구하고 싶을 정도로
마음에 드는
제품이에요 년 말부터이 대림이
시즌마다 출시된 걸로 알고 있는데
이번 시즌에도 발매했으니 와이드한
빈티지 대님을 보시는 분들은 한 번쯤
고려해 보시는 걸
추천드립니다 마지막은 제가 유일하게
똑같은 제품을 두 번 구매한 아르켓의
루즈 스트레이트 진입니다 제가이
바질에 처음 구매한 건 2017년
여름이에요 런던에 여행을 갔다가 그
당시에 처음 생긴 아르켓 매장에서
입어보고 바로 구매했습니다 그게이
바지의 첫 번째 구매예요 한국에
돌아와서도 막 열심히 입었는데 갑자기
이사할 때 보니까이 바지가 사라진
거예요 아르케이 한국에 생기긴
했지만이 루즈 스트레이트 핏은 처음에
제 기억으로는
없었습니다 그래서 기다리고 문의하고
찾아보고 하다가 결국 한국에 입고되고
바로 두 번째로
구매했습니다 제 기준에서이 바지의
장점은 단점이 없다는 겁니다 뭐 미리
기리 바지통 워싱 그외에 작은
디테일까지 딱히 흠잡을게 없어요 집
사몬 스이고 튼튼해서 무릎도 잘 안
늘어납니다 루즈 스트레이트 핏이라는
이름이지만 세미 와이드라고 생각하시면
됩니다 그다지 취향에 치우치지 않는
실루엣이라 휘뚜루 마트루 입기 안성
맞춤이에요 그리고 뭐 유니클로 만큼은
아니지만 하나 사놓고 쭉 입기에
근처는
가격입니다이 바지는 사이즈가 조금
크게 나와서 저는 한 사이즈 작게
29로 구매했습니다 사람마다 조금씩
허벅지 통이나 기장의 차이 등이
있으니까 한번 입어보고 구매하시는 걸
추천드립니다 입어 보시면 아마 저와
비슷하게 아주 무난히 잘 입겠다는
생각을 하실
겁니다이 바지는 그런데 유려한
느낌보다 좀 투박한 느낌이 강해서
캐주얼한 무드가 더 나을 것 같습니다
그래서 개인적으로는 스니커즈가 좀 더
잘 어울리는 그런 바지라고 생각해요
봄이오면 겨울에 잘 못 입던 여러
가지 옷들이 생각나고 또 꺼내 입지만
저는 그중에 중청 청바지가 가장 먼저
생각나더라고요 뭔가 그 초록초록한
봄에이 청색이 잘 어울려서 그런 것
같습니다 댓글과 DM 요청 주시는
내용들도 조금씩 준비해 보고
있으니까요 제가 소개해 드리고 싶은
것과 잘 버무려서 올려보도록
하겠습니다 오늘 제 이야기는
여기까지입니다
감사합니다